from look of it offsets wearing the
classic card eh attorney so this is one
of the first woods they ever produced
it's a favorite for many reasons it's
just a great Universal fit this is one
of their most popular frames but also
one of the hardest to get these days
because it's been out of production for
over 20 years almost like a Jordan one
right Cartier is really a detroit thing
growing up out there that's all
everybody wants seen everybody out there
wearing Cartier's it's the best quality
frame you could buy it's been going on
since eighties and this was my style
that originally came from the streets of
Detroit and from the jewelers out there
small independent guys were icing these
for a lot of the Detroit rappers and it
really ended up catching on across the
road it's really great to see the
resurgence of Cartier glasses now in
2017 18 19 going into 2020 artists from
the migos your name Jeannette to young
thug Rick Ross you know they put in
heavy ice on the Cartier you're not just
buying the glasses you're you paying
triple to put the ice on it so it's very
interesting
our dealer can mean a lot of things
explain it simply it's anybody who sells
sunglasses that can be your local
optician a sunglasses down to the
specialty guys like me where I have
niche market hard-to-find frames that
are typically not found in stores so I
work with the network of all different
dealers we still shops
collectors all around the world and
sometimes I find that some old product
but other times I buy them fix them up
refurbished I'm put my own twist on them
and custom tins sometimes add diamonds
rubies you know there's no limit to what
you can do with these frames I've worked
with a lot of people in the rap game a
lot of artists a lot of athletes it's a
small community of us you know most the
time we all know each other we work
together really there's not that many
so kardia glasses typically are made out
of one of four different materials and
that's buffalo would wire classic buffs
are what I have on my face right now
these are diamond white buffs vs
diamonds added by hutches jewelry out in
Detroit every pair has its own unique
markings and there's a couple different
colors they come in white brown black
gray woods right here this is called the
G Bernie really classic Detroit style
wireframes anything with the gold or
platinum on we're going down the side
get into the plastics which could be you
know something like this right here this
is a holographic plastic green
cardiovert eyes so there's a lot of
different materials that they make from
look of it offsets wearing the classic
car D etre Bernie so this is one of the
first woods they ever produced
it's a favorite for many reasons it's
just a great Universal fit this is one
of their most popular frames but also
one of the hardest to get these days
because it's been out of production for
over 20 years
almost like a Jordan one right then we
have Cueva over here crazy bus style
offs carnea journeys which I have I use
from the bridge
the sees everything and take off last
but not least I'm not sure what
particular style of car today is women
but I would imagine it's not your cliche
type his choice isn't I wear them for
takeoff usually a lot different a lot he
doesn't go for the normal like woods and
the things that you'll see is of the two
members usually you're coming a
different style I really appreciate him
for doing that this is what take off
heads so but just a clear lens and I
start having all that just the
customization lens an ice it almost
creates a whole new pair of glasses and
as you continue to sneak me goes heavy
icing knowing them for having heavy ice
on their eyewear that's their look best
their style that's the image because as
you see how tall the high weather the
hill they wear these just particular
stop the most these are not rhinestone
these are real diamonds also these guys
are dropping a lot of money on these
frames ten thousand or more Claypool's
wearing the platinum version of this
card eh attorney and he ended up fully
flooding the frame adding diamonds all
around every space possible ice it's
really known for wearing those and I
know he wears a lot of Gotti's to the 5
aways he's really big into the round and
oval shapes I've worked with all three
of these guys and I gotta say all of
them are really up on their fashion huge
collectors frames and gear in general
it's really amazing to see young
evolution in the acessories and fashion
coming from Atlanta being paying
attention to his career at least for the
last six years to see where he's at as
just a collection of clothes accessories
and nice things and I really appreciate
him always finding new ways to express
himself you know and finding things that
work for his face so here they're
wearing the white bucks Colorado Buffalo
horn exactly like what I'm wearing right
now
three-piece rimless frame well that's
all cost somewhere this is one of the
most popular frames I saw I would have
to say those would probably be at say
around 7 or 8 grand but I really would
have to see the hilarity and you know
the carat weight of the stones on there
so majority of those are actually custom
although cardioid does make some crazy
expensive they can get up to a hundred
thousand or more most of ones you see
with the diamonds going all the way
around the lens that's custom for
rimless frames you can adjust and do
what you need to do very fast literally
unscrews and then usually it's jewelers
either they had a bracket on there it
started on or they set it directly into
the metal the money that you want to
spend with determines a diamond that you
receive it could be cheap you know
twenty five hundred fifteen hundred
dollars worth of work it's gonna look
like fifteen hundred and then you could
spend a hundred thousand and you don't
know what a hundred thousand look like
it's really cool as we've seen everybody
put their own unique spin on it too and
just icing it their own way every rapper
every jeweler has their own way of
probably like things done you know it
can be channel-set wrong side princess
cuts but guys there's so many different
ways you can customize driveway you
could do the bridge the arms it's
limitless the different options you have
when it comes to ice when it comes to a
rimless frame you can adjust the size or
shape to anything you want whether you
want octagon hearts circles anything
compared to a normal plastic frame
there's nothing you could do to this you
know you have to take it out in
[Music]
we need to understand the size of your
face to understand the glasses this
particular Cartier comes in a lot of
different sizes I would imagine from
Rick Ross the Big Show they have a
different sized face they both have on
the same glasses so you got to
understand your size if Rick Ross was to
put on big shots glasses you probably
wouldn't like it if I'd be upset because
it it wouldn't be comfortable you have
to find your size and then you find a
size you can continue to Isis and do
whatever you want that's why it's
important to find your size every frame
has a unique set of numbers that can
help you identify the size and not even
just as Cartier all brands have this so
for example this is a Cartier mom Mason
the numbers for the lens and the bridge
would be on the inside right here so
this for example is a 56:19 so that's
fifty six across here in millimeters
nineteen millimeters across the bridge
on the inside it's a 135 so that's the
arm length so some are longer some are
shorter depending on how your ears are
on a wire frame while your glasses frame
that can be extended and vent out by
your optician
so anywhere around here can be adjusted
now guys and we've done a lot of talking
and we've told you laughs about glasses
but I know that there's a person out
there that only cares about one thing
what do expensive frames really look
like what are expensive frames when did
you really spend a bag on some frames
thank you to our good brother hutch we
really outdid ourselves I like to say
with these babies right here so that's
about 400 baguette diamonds of 12 carats
this lens took a year and a half to even
make the lens so nobody in the world has
this lens on these redwoods as you can
see we did the white gold going across
and this is a custom star tray that he
had to make to put the custom lens that
literally I'm these are the only time
you've ever seen these no one from the
me goes to Jesus
the first time that ever been done wit
Cartier they pay homage to some of my
favorite people like Bootsy Collins
George Clinton no this is the what
anywhere from like eighteen to twenty
thousand dollars of like I'm a pair of
glasses based off original images of
Bootsy Collins from his interviews album
covers really collaborated took a long
time to get the shake perfect
so brimless frame we ended up turning it
into a full rim frame with the baguettes
around Ackley's glasses is something
that we're truly passionate about and
something that we want people to
understand the frames that fit your face
because each frame comes with a
different type of confidence and we want
you to have that same confidence the
options with cartier glasses are
limitless as you can see so have fun go
copy your first Ben Cardin ears
[Music]